We now come to the hypothesis test unit number 2 and we just put together
what we've learned in the previous hypothesis test unit and in the unit on confidence intervals.
This ends up to be the dominant way of doing hypothesis testing.
We arrive at a very simple formula that we can even program.
According to Wikipedia in the 2007-2008 season,
the average NBA basketball player was 6 feet and 6.98 inches tall.
That is the same as 200.66 cm or for the sake of this exercise, just 200 cm.
Let me question this and see if this is actually acceptable.
Go to a training game for NBA players.
Here they are training, and I drag all of the players in the side and I take their height.
As I take those measurements, I find, here the sizes I've observed.
In fact, I got everything from 199 cm to 206 in 1 cm increment.
And now, I want to ask the two-sided hypothesis test question
whether I shall reject the claim that the average player
in the NBA is 200 cm at a 95% confidence level. The trick goes as follows.
You learned about confidence intervals, which is the mean plus/minus a factor taken from the T-table
times a square root of the empirical variance over N.
That formula you've not seen many times in practice.
When I plug this in here with the appropriate (a), I get for the mean 202.5 ± 1.916.
If you want to check this, I'm using 2.365 for (a).
Graphically, what this means is if here is the 200 and here are my data points,
the mean measurement of the sample sits over here and the 95% confidence level stops at 200.58,
just short of 200, and that means we reject the hypothesis of 200 cm
based on our sample of 8 people, because the confidence interval doesn't quite make it here.
Now, I should argue that this isn't quite correct in practice depending on what town I go to,
I might find a different sample and a different town.
We say we didn't pick these people completely independently and it isn't accounted here.
That's just a word of caution, but I think you get the principle. It's really simple.
Use your confidence interval and check whether the outcome
lies within or outside the confidence interval.